why are prices going up well jonathan
it's a classic case this of how energy
prices energy security can filter down
to all aspects of our life including
where we get our food from now one of
the key reasons is how we generate power
has been hit by things like weather
last few months wind production has been
cut quite significantly and so has solar
and we generate worldwide quite a lot of
energy from
these particular types of energy
generation methods that has led to a
spike in the gas price the wholesale gas
price that's the price that energy
companies buy gas in and then they sell
it on to us and that's what's fueling
these concerns that we might see a rise
in energy prices now that will have a
knock-on effect for all sorts of
different types of industries ultimately
though it will all filter down to each
and every household now the spike in
demand has caused a hike in prices
that's going to have a huge knock-on
effect one one key example of this is
two fertilizer plants in the united
kingdom have had to close because of
these uh high price hikes they produce
carbon dioxide and carbon dioxide is key
for agriculture in the uk it's key for
um slaughtering animals it's also key
for packaging and that's led to concerns
we might see a shortage of food
specifically meat and that could be
chicken and pork now today the business
secretary quasi quarten is meeting food
producers and i think he's also meeting
members of off gem the the energy
regulator and he's tweeted today and
it's unusual that he's meeting today on
a saturday so this gives us an
indication of how serious it is now he's
tweeted uh today he said i'll be
speaking to chief executives of the uk's
largest energy suppliers and operators
to discuss the global gas
situation he goes on to say
energy security is an absolute well he
says britain has a diverse range of gas
supply sources with sufficient capacity
to more than meet demand we do not
expect he says supply
emergencies now that's easier said than
done given it how internet
interconnected all of this is so it
started with problems of energy
generation it's now filtering down to
suspicions that we could see shortages
of food now add to this already a huge
and growing problem of our supply
network here in the uk we've got a huge
shortage of hgv drivers partly caused by
covid restrictions partly caused by
brexit immigration measures which has
cut the amount of european drivers able
to drive around in the uk and you have
the beginnings of possible beginnings of
increased supply problems which could
affect what you see on the shelves
meat supplies and this that and the
other so the business secretary on a
saturday clearly trying to figure out
the picture by meeting food producers
and also members of off gem the energy
regulator to try and figure out whether
this is a short-term problem or whether
this is something that strategically the
government need to be worried about